I just watched the scariest movie on
Netflix Veronica with all my friends we
just had our socks scared off of us we
had a ton of fun I love watching movies
with my friends here's what went down
[Music]
Veronica a Spanish horror movie that is
currently considered the most horrifying
movie on Netflix
[Music]
so Chris you're the only one here who
has seen the movie what are we getting
into it's pretty scary it's somewhat
based on a true story the police report
I guess was like the first there was a
police report it was a police report now
actually like used paranormal as like
his reasoning for the case so that makes
it like kind of legit I'm scared of like
a supernatural side the side you can't
see I don't know
supernatural no human can we deal with
that I don't like the idea of being
possessed cuz it's like you're your own
worst enemy is that one of my biggest
fears quite honestly so we're all
wearing heartrate monitors right now
great we'll be checking in during the
movie to see how scared we are based on
how our heart rate goes up and down and
hopefully everyone's will be there no
one's gonna die do we want to play a
drinking game yes yes while we get
through this I feel like any time
there's a jump scare that's a drink any
other rules every five seconds that's a
set
[Laughter]
I'm seeing already you better do it I'm
just drinking until the TV shows up guys
this is something scary gonna happen now
every one of those I think yeah I want
to burst into tears someone say yes No
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
'we don't iike
everyone's rank everyone's rank I'm
sweating right now
I have a question you see these
Apocalypse movies all this like bad
horror movies why do most people die
they die sir like oh my god my husband
something's wrong with it let me go
check on him
what you gotta do is run away that's why
I would survive like a zombie apocalypse
someone's acting weird um oh there must
be something supernatural I play yes
once she opened her mouth I would have
sprinted rinse it away like and I would
say hope yo she's in the basement she's
doing some weirdly witch stuff I don't
know I'm pretty protective and I think
if my friend was doing then I'd probably
try to shake it out of her I would need
at least 20 minutes of pure panic before
I got a real good thing together so just
be chaos
do you mind everyone I'm war today
she knows that smoking none is my idol
mm-hmm and she's gonna be the new
wallpaper on my fan but we're gonna do a
round of mean this with the smoking nun
we'll start with Chris and you need you
to give me your best caption for the
smokin guys this could be like a new
format like the Kermit with the tea but
it could be like that's none of my
business
no in the patriarchy he tries to get you
down it would be a picture of Carrie
Bradshaw smoking from Sex in the City
and it would be me at 29 and it would be
this picture straight up it would be
Lucifer I haven't heard that name in
years
well I'm terrified see that's why you
can be missing a book cult and Ouija
boards has for professionals you got to
know what you're doing before you enter
anything
[Music]
actually has anyone died yet no that's
not a good sorry I just want to let
anyone know my heart rate is 112 I
genuinely don't have how this ends
oh no no no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Wow 97 over 68 so 68
you're way too chill right now - 97 over
102 which I feel like what's not good
hold on guys that can't be right not my
finger it's shaky I've literally never
been calmer it's 97 over 66 fine is 95
over 85 I feel like that's not good Wow
mines 494 over 111 so I'm having a heart
attack
okay guys let's play a little game of
Veronica would you rather would you
rather participate in a seance using a
Ouija board or spend a night in the room
of the woman
Veronica is based off of I'm spending
nowhere I'm not doing with no Ouija oh
all right
would you rather date someone who
participates in ug board seances or
somewhat wait with us or someone who
puts if they put pineapple on their
pizza they don't have very good taste so
the fact that they want to date me would
be a slight against me it doesn't mean
you don't have good taste
it simply means that you think
pineapples amazing and yeah you have
terrible taste and you need to rethink
your shirt it's very
so guys we just watch Veronica and how
scary do you think not that was my god
that was intense
psychologically probably like actually
being scary outside six would you get
six or seven like there were a lot of
moments where I was like sweating yeah
but yeah like psychologically I what I
liked about the film is that the heights
kept getting greater and greater and
when it got to the climax of the film
you are attached to this character
I wasn't attached to her until she had
nobody it's me a bad sequel Veronica a
bad sequel or great sequel her younger
siblings take out the Ouija board to try
to talk to her like Veronica - Veronica
I think my sequel would be the demon net
so all the demons that possessed her you
know fight for your love and everyone
will start with you crazy give me one
big reason to see Veronica actually I
feel like it's a better movie than most
horror movies that they put out our noun
right now movies are the ones that you
talk about a lot with your friends
afterwards because everyone takes a
different thing away from it so I think
this is a really good movie cuz it's
like we could probably talk about this
for hours I think there's a lot of
metaphors that we didn't even pick up on
and this movie was actually pretty good
I loved Veronica's eyebrows she's got
great
that's all I got that's what I expected
I feel like this movie for me why you
should go see it is because it's like
life you know you freaked out you're
uncomfortable and then you realize
everything is bullcrap and then you
accept it and you move on guys thanks
for watching Veronica with us I'm sweaty
scared and tired and I'm nervous about
what we're gonna watch next because that
was pretty intense right guys comedy I'm
emotionally did way
[Music]